out here in the Indian Ocean there's a
lot of emptiness but if you scan long
enough you'll see something right here
equidistant between Africa and Australia
you'll see a cluster of incredibly
remote bits of land hardly peeking out
of the ocean this is the Chagos
archipelago a chain of around 60 remote
atolls and Islands a thousand or so
kilometers from any landmass there used
to be people here
local Islanders who lived here for many
generations
but those Islanders are gone now and
today the main island called Diego
Garcia looks like this it's a United
States military base and instead of a
local community of coconut farmers this
island is now a little slice of America
transplanted into one of the most remote
places on earth
but this weaponized island doesn't even
belong to the United States it's
technically British territory that was
secretly rented to the US in a covert
deal 50 years ago so what's going on
here what's the deal with this American
base on a technically British island and
whatever happened to the thousands of
Islanders that used to live on this side
[Music]
the British gained control of the Chagos
archipelago in 1814 taking it from the
French the few thousand locals that
lived in this chain of Island mainly
worked in coconut cultivation for
European companies but by the middle of
the 1900s the UN had been founded and
one of the first things that it
undertook was decolonizing the map
basically getting all these empires to
wind down their rule over their colonies
so the British started leaving much of
its territory abroad downsizing its
empire around the same time the US was
kind of doing the opposite looking to
expand its military power and influence
around the world they wanted a base in
the Indian Ocean where they didn't have
any territories so the u.s. set their
sights on this archipelago specifically
this main island called Diego Garcia all
of these islands were a part of
Mauritius which was a British colony at
the time but Mauritius was soon becoming
independent from Britain part of this
decolonizing of the map Britain would
soon be giving these islands back to the
people who lived there so the u.s. made
a secret deal with their allies the
British at the time the British owed the
United States a bunch of money for
helping them develop these submarine
missiles so the u.s. said that they
would wipe out fourteen million dollars
worth of that debt if the British could
secure them this island but remember
that the British were close to leaving
all of these islands trying to
decolonize so they pulled a fast one and
told Mauritius that they could have
their independence plus three million
pounds if they would let the British
just kind of break off this little
archipelago so that the British could
hold on to it even as Mauritius gained
independence from Britain
the reason they paid the three million
pounds is so that they could technically
say that they purchased the islands and
appear as if they were still in keeping
with the UN effort of decolonizing the
map and yet they were still able to hold
on to these islands for the US the US
and the UK didn't sign any treaties or
formally transfer any money during this
process all of that would require
congressional approval and public
scrutiny and all of these things that
would
make it not possible so instead they
kept the deal secret
like literally secret like in the
letters that they wrote back and forth
they said quote there is a secret
agreement and that the US would quote
effectively but indirectly pay the
British for these islands meaning there
was no money changing hands but they
still paid them by wiping out the debt
and that they would be taking quote
special measures to maintain the secrecy
of this arrangement
oh and there was the fact that this
letter was officially classified as
secret so yeah when I say secret I
really mean secret by the late 1960s it
was looking like the Americans were
gonna get their base in the Indian Ocean
they were ready to move in but there was
still one big problem here which is that
there were over a thousand locals still
on this main island of Diego Garcia but
in the eyes of the US and the UK this
wasn't a problem in a government memo
the British assured the Americans that
there will be no indigenous population
except the seagulls and indeed they made
good on their promise the locals were
herded onto cargo ships and shipped off
to the islands of Mauritius and the
Seychelles and they were left there in a
world that many of them had never seen
before to fend for themselves many had
never worked outside of their Island
that no skills in a way of getting work
back on the island their pets were
rounded up and gassed their houses left
to crumble the indigenous population was
gone
[Music]
and then the building began
the US now had their base in the middle
of the Indian Ocean giving them direct
access to big regional hotspots like the
Middle East and Asia
Diego Garcia became more and more
militarized with time soon it had a
deep-sea port where nuclear submarines
could dock and it soon took on the
nickname the footprint of freedom and
yet with time it became more and more
secretive no journalists are allowed to
visit Diego Garcia few civilians have
ever arrived here and among those
civilians by the way are NFL
cheerleaders who came to boost morale of
the troops the island was also used as a
CIA black site used to interrogate
suspects after 9/11 both the US and the
British government's denied this and
then finally admitted it we did some
things that were wrong we tortured some
folks after 9/11 this island became more
important because it was a launch pad
for the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan so
a new housing complex was built to
accommodate the influx of soldiers this
new complex is called Camp justice
speaking of justice those Islanders who
were forcibly evicted and deported from
their Island yeah they wanted some of it
so over the years they've been fighting
for some form of justice
and the British government has tried to
compensate them sometimes with money or
by giving them an option to become
British citizens but even still many
live in very difficult circumstances
displaced from their homeland what they
really want is to go back and through
years of legal action they've made a
strong case that they have a right to do
so well the Foreign Office review its
current position on the Pacheco's
Islanders who should be granted
immediately the right to repatriation in
their home we are a currently in dispute
with Mauritius about the issue of these
you gaussian Islanders and about I Diego
Garcia remember all those in direct
payments and loopholes that the British
and u.s. pulled during decolonization
that stuff that they made very clear was
very very secret well last year the
International Court of Justice ruled
that this was totally illegal and not in
compliance with the process of
decolonizing the General Assembly of the
UN voted 116 to 6 that the UK never
decolonized Mauritius because they held
on to this archipelago and
halt for them to immediately finish the
process of returning the archipelago to
the people who lived there but despite
these legal rulings and this global
consensus the US and the UK aren't
likely to budge the UK continues to
defend its claim to this island and as
long as they do the US military will
have a home there in this country we're
doing our best to ensure that we are
Asmus humane has been possibly thank you
so much for watching this video there's
so much more information on this topic
that I was able to fit into this video
but I wanted to make it four years and I
finally did I want to thank story blocks
for supporting this channel and for
sponsoring today's video you may not
have noticed but a lot of the footage
that I used especially in the intro of
this piece was story box footage this
moment right here in the intro resume in
that's all story blocks footage it's
beautiful stuff
and I was able to browse and find loads
of stuff of the ocean and islands that I
was able to use in this video i've been
using story blocks for years because
they really are the best place to find
good stock footage and audio and After
Effects templates for so incredibly
cheap you have access to a giant
repository of visuals that you can use
to create whatever you're creating I
could have never gone to the Indian
Ocean to record this footage and yet on
story blocks I have a huge abundance of
stuff I can use so I'm so grateful that
it exists and grateful that it's
affordable I'm grateful that it is a
subscription service so you don't paper
clip you pay a monthly subscription
which is incredibly cheap and then you
can just download as much of this big
beautiful footage as you want
super high-res I can't say enough about
it and again that's not just because
they sponsored this video I've been
using story blocks for years so I have a
link in my description its story blocks
calm slash Johnny Harris if you go to
that link and go sign up for story
blocks it definitely helps support my
channel but it definitely will help you
support whatever you're doing if you are
a creative a filmmaker
wants to learn how to edit better the
story blocks is a great way to have tons
of footage at your fingertips for an
incredibly low price Thank You story
blocks for sponsoring this video thank
you all for watching lots more to come
soon have a good day
[Music]